Hey, if you haven't already got it. Get yourself a copy of answer the internet,
the card game it's available right now. And the link in the bio,
or you can get a Barstool, sports, Walmart, Amazon,
or Spencer gifts play along with us. Let's get into it. I'll be honest. Pappas.
I'm Chris DiStefano and we are the history hyenas podcast.
We're here to answer the internet again.
Again.
So Yani pops,
would you rather shoot webs like Spiderman or have claws,
like Wolverine, both come out of your deck. I'd like to shoot webs.
You like to shoot. Why do I have claws coming out of my deck? I got chlamydia.
I guess you could call me Chrissy. Wolverine. Cause I got a drip,
but I like to shoot webs. You can just walk around and give dudes, facials
them. Just shoot and rope. Yeah. I like how we always shift around.
Like we're like listening to the national Anthem game.
We're about ready to get on the and go guy, athletes. We're going into play.
Women's volleyball. Okay. If you were murdered,
would you be the most light if you were merging
[inaudible] too close together yet? I can't see.
I can't see if you were murdered, who would be the most likely suspect?
My baby's mom,
if I was murdered, the most likely suspect would be me. I hate my life.
I'm going to kill myself. What it is.
You can turn any movie into a porno with the same cast from the
movie. Which movie are you picking? Wreck-It Ralph.
I am definitely going with OB.
Stella's got her groove back. That would be,
you don't even have to ch I jerked off to it and it wasn't even a porno.
It wasn't even. Yeah, I got it. I took off to a lot. The movie true lies.
When Jamie Lee Curtis is dancing around with Arnold Schwarzenegger,
I would jerk off to that a lot.
And it's weird that I jerk off to that because she looks exactly like one of my
aunts. No, I was saying it was worth it.
It was weird because you can't see Arnold Schwartzenegger he's in black.
So that's weird if you,
if you could make your girlfriend's breasts as large as you wanted,
but yours would be the same size. How big would you go?
If I could make her breasts as big as I wanted,
but yours have to be the same size. I'll go for hers.
All you got right now. I think we're at the same size right now.
I'm just going to say you push it on seeds, right? How you know,
I'm not in shape because my point away from each other,
they look like they're in a fight with each other.
My look like they're not talking to each other. I need to lose some weight.
You want your to go? North, South doors are going East, West side.
Now you want it. You want mine to be like this. You want the airplane guy?
Who's doing traffic to go down. And for me, I don't care. What size?
My girlfriends, one weird tan.
I got one weird temp and I don't care what size my girlfriend's breast her.
Cause I'm into guys. Would you rather be the president,
the Pope or whoever is in charge of North Korea? You know what? The president,
the Pope in North Korea,
I'm going to go the Pope because I think he could get away with more.
I mean that whole church has been molesting kids for centuries and they're doing
better than ever. If one person molested someone here at Barstool,
there be no more Barstool.
I would say the pulp or whoever leads North Korea now.
Cause it's disrespectful to even think I have the talent or the capability or
the wherewithal to be the president because we got the best president we'll ever
have in our life. Right now track 2020. I respect fricking that ding Jong
[inaudible]. I mean, he, he looks at,
he walks around like Asian Cartman and like, he's like,
nobody's challenging him. Like, can you, like, if you were in Korea,
would you be like, I'm not listening to this guy anymore.
He's five foot six and he's fat. Yeah. He's fat.
And I left all my friends in Brooklyn when they see Kim knew and they just think
it's Ken Jong. They think it's the same guy because they're dumb kids.
And we want to watch you read that one. Okay.
Would you watch a porn with the hottest girl from high school?
If the dude in it was your dad? What? Yeah,
because the truth in this situation is like,
see my dad's piece more than I care for.
We used to make me take showers with them and the kids got a slinky Dick.
He's got a little piece. I've already seen his bare penis.
So for me it doesn't matter. Yeah. We actually talk about that a lot.
Like our dads both have micro penises. My dad's piece looks like chewing gum.
Cotton. Yeah. Yeah. No. My dad would want to see him in a porno.
Now my dad's piece, I would describe it as an Annie.
Would you rather be magic Johnson with AIDS or a regular dude with
no brainer. I'm going to magic Johnson with AIDS. They're curing AIDS.
I don't give a crap. I'm more scared of bedbugs.
I can't believe I still don't have it. You're a lucky kid. Yeah.
I'm a lucky cat, but yeah. Okay, good. What movie most recently made?
I can't even think of a movie. I even watched of podcast. Yeah.
I don't even listen to movies. You know what a girl's got to eat.
It makes you cry from feeling good. One movie most recently made me cry.
Pocahontas. I watched Pocahontas with my daughter and it's just, it's up.
When they kill a brother. If you had to eat one human body part,
what would it be? Guy's penis next, next, next.
And I'm keto. So I would say if you have to eat one human body part,
what would it be? Ida ID to somebodies nipples. I'm going penis.
Just to make it funny. If you got to eat a body part,
you want to be able to giggle about it and be like, what'd you see?
I'm like I ate a guy's Dick. It has, it takes the bite off of what you just did.
Yeah. Yeah. I need a placenta. People need publicizes.
That's great thinking right there. Yeah.
Is eating out a stripper at a bachelor party,
something to brag about or is it just disgusting
to eating at a shipper at a bachelor party? Something to brag about? Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. You'd have to strip her. Yeah. I went to, why would it be disgusting?
What kind of gay guy wrote this is this, this card got in there from a grinder.
This is like, this is this one slipped in. This is what we call a raisin.
What we mean by that is, is when you're a guy you have sex with so many women,
inevitably, a couple of guys are going to slip it on.
We call those rates like you don't notice two razors in a wrote meal.
You don't notice a gay guy's car. But the only thing with this,
if you're eating out a stripper at a bachelor party,
you're not going to be able to do it for long.
And you can get like two licks in before you get hemmed up by some black dude.
Who's there to say, don't touch the girl.
I'm going to get your hands off the strippers. I'm going to say it's disgusting.
Cause vaginas are ULI.
Would you rather have your girl be able to see or hear everything you do when
she's not around?
So do you want to grow to see it or hear it when she's not around?
I'd rather her hear it. You'd rather her hear.
I don't want her to see what's going on. Cause not a good scene. Yeah.
Cause what I do is I get completely naked.
I tucked back and I walk around listening to wild horses.
This kid used to um, yeah, he used to wear his mother's are pantyhose.
It's not a good luck. It's not a good luck. Yeah. It's not a good look.
What I walk around in full Maurissa outfit and I just jerk off to myself in the
mirror. I would rather, yeah,
I definitely rather her just I'd rather her hear it because I'm all
I do is lie. I just CWL Chrissy white lies and I'm just tell lies all the time.
So if she heard it, I could at least get out of it. Cause if she saw it,
she would call the police. Want to read the last one? Sure. Okay.
Would you kill baby Hitler?
If it had to be in a very gruesome way while I'm 40% German.
So I plead the fifth when you kill baby Hitler,
if it had to be in a very gruesome way, do I know he's Hitler,
Adolf, Hitler as a baby. Yeah.
I'm kicking that little off of a high bridge and just ratchet him.
[inaudible] I'm actually no, you got to give him the Jews.
I give Hitler to Jews. Give Hitler. I'd be like,
I'd wait for like one of their holidays or whatever.
And I'd show up at that shack that they build outside their houses, like knock,
knock, and got a little present for baby Hill.
Or they'd be like who's baby Hillary. I'm like, trust me.
You're going to want to kill this place. Me.
This is the best Hanukkah gift you've ever gotten. They're going to go. No,
we don't kill people. That's very bad to don't want the only one.
How do I know I'm not going to kill a baby member and be like, listen,
the guy I'm from the future. Things get bad. Here's kill this baby.
Here's what he's going to do with it and say,
we're going to make them tota fix and I'm going to go. No, trust me,
this guy's going to be doing some bad stuff to you. People killed this baby.
[Inaudible].